oui il faut prôner une convergence
mondiale en matière d'intelligence
artificielle générative et je me
félicite que l'Union européenne soit à
la manœuvre l'acte pour l'IA que nous
avons initié il y a quelques semaines
sera sans aucun doute une base pour un
standard mondial néanmoins les IA
génératifs posent des défis sectoriels
comme dans le monde de la culture et de
la création comment distinguer une
oeuvre produite par l'intelligence
artificielle d'une véritable oeuvre
créée par un artiste avec l'aide de Lia
quel statut juridique donner à ses
œuvres comment s'assurer que nos
créateurs européens soient justement
compensés pour les œuvres qui sont
aspirées dans les bases d'entraînement
de ces modèles à nous Européens de peser
dans le débat mondial pour concilier
propriété intellectuelles innovation et
démocratisation à nous Européens de
faire de la culture un secteur de
premier plan dans la régulation mondiale
de Lia merci